COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE CUPBOARD
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PRESIDENT THE SENATE CHAMBER SO
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
BEGINNER HEARING. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH LIMITED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. YOU'LL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX.
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN AGAIN
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE
SIX. FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO
SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT AGAIN
SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IS
IMPORTANT WE'RE ABLE TO HEAR
FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THIS CHAIR I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IT'S CUSTOMARY MANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE TO
CONNECTIONS MUTED. TODAY WE HAVE
ONE BILL ON THE AGENDA AS BEFORE
SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR BATES.
ONE TWO HI SEVEN. BEFORE YOUR
PRESENTATION THE BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
SEVENTEEN QUORUM PAN HERE PAN
HERE MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S HERE
EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HERE GROVE GROVE HERE
HER TADO LEYVA HERE LEVI HERE
LEE MON YEAH THE MOON HERE ROSS
. ROTH HERE RUBIO PRESIDENT
RUBIO HERE WINNER OKAY YEAH OKAY
THANK YOU THE CONSULTANT NOTES A
CORN HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED SO NOW
BEGAN WITH OUR- S. BEATS FOR
SEVENTY THREE ITEM NUMBER ONE
CENTRE BATES WELL COME. UP
PLEASE BEGIN TO PREPARE THESE
THAT BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR
PANEL MEMBERS AND I WOULD LIKE
TO FIRST BEGIN WITH A BIG THANK
YOU TO DR PAN IN THE COMMITTEE.
OUR STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
DEAL I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO EXCLUDE FROM ANY DEDUCTIBLES
THE EQUIPMENT AND SUPPLIES FOR
THE MEDICALLY NECESSARY
MANAGEMENT AND TREATMENT OF
DIABETES. SENATE BILL FOUR
SEVENTY THREE WILL HELP ADDRESS
THE HIGH TREATMENT COSTS FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
THIS DISEASE I INTRODUCED THIS
BILL AFTER LEARNING ABOUT THE
COST OF DIABETIC TREATMENT FROM
ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS. IT WILL
PLACE A CAP ON CO PAYS
DEDUCTIBLES COINSURANCE OR OTHER
COST SHARING REQUIREMENT
REQUIREMENT. ON AN INSULIN
PRESCRIPTION OF THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER MONTH PER EACH
DOSAGE FORM OF INSULIN PRODUCTS
DIABETES IS A CHRONIC DISEASE
WAS SHORT AND LONG TERM HEALTH
EFFECTS THAT PREVENT THE PROPER
PRODUCTION OF. INDOOR RESPONSE
TO INSULIN A HORMONE THAT
FACILITATE THE TRANSFER OF
GLUCOSE INTO CELLS TO PROVIDE
ENERGY MAINTAINING A PROPER
BLOOD SUGAR LEVEL IS CRITICAL TO
MAINTAINING GOOD HEALTH AND
PREVENTING COMPLICATIONS WHICH
CAN BE LIFE THREATENING FOR
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES. PEOPLE
WITH THIS DISEASE SPEND TWO TO
THREE TIMES MORE ON HEALTH CARE
EXPENSES WHEN A PERSON WITHOUT
THE CONDITION THE AVERAGE LIST
PRICE OF BRAND NAME INSULIN
NEARLY TRIPLED BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN EVEN THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZED THE HIGH COST OF
INSULIN IN HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
YESTERDAY. THE RISING COST OF
INSULIN HAS AFFECTED PEOPLE WITH
THIS DISEASE. FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED LIFE SUSTAINING INSULIN AND
CANNOT AFFORD IT THE CHOICES ARE
FRIGHTENING THEY CAN FIND
THEMSELVES BETWEEN CHOOSING
INSULIN OR PUTTING FOOD ON THEIR
TABLES. THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE NO
ONE SHOULD HAVE TO RATION THEIR
INSULIN DUE TO COST YES BEFORE
SEVENTY THREE WILL GIVE PEOPLE
WITH DIABETES CERTAINTY ON HEIR
MAXIMUM COST SHARING FOR THEIR
LIFE SAVING INSULIN. WHICH ALLOW
THEM TO FOCUS ON MANAGING THEIR
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. I HAVE WITH
ME TODAY TO WITNESSES CARI ****
MY CONSTITUENT FIVE KNOWN CARS
AND SHE WAS ELEVEN YEARS OLD HAS
BEEN A CONSTITUENCY IN. THAT
TIME AND IS A FAMILY FRIEND MY
SECOND WITNESSES SHARE GONZALEZ
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
DIABETES ASSOCIATION. RIGHT
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES- BEFORE
WE BEGIN WITH THE TESTIMONY I
JUST WANT TO MAKE MENTION THAT-
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE CHAIR WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME.
IT'S TOLD TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS WITH A TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE REGISTER
TERROR OPERATIVE STIRRED
TESTIMONY IN FAVOR IN
OPPOSITION. ALL OTHERS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MEASURE SO WE HAVE TO- WITNESSES
AS NOTED BY THE CENTRE BATES WHO
HAVE REGISTERED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- SO MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON TO THE LINE KERRY ****
AND SHARE GONZALEZ. WOULD BEGIN
WITH. GARY **** YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES IF YOU GO OVER THAT TIME
THAT WILL COME OUT THE TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES TIME SO THAT'LL
REDUCE THEM OUT TIME FOR MISS
GONZALEZ SO. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN WITH- TERRY **** THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR MY
NAME. IS KARLEY **** AND I LIVE
IN A LEAP TO BEING HOME. WITH MY
HUSBAND AND MY TWO SONS THE
BASTION IN THEODORE. I'M HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT MY UNCLE
BASTION. RASKIN IS SEVEN YEARS
OLD HE LOVED PAPA TROLL MATTHEW
BUILDING WITH LEGOS. HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH A LIFE
THREATENING AUTOIMMUNE DISEASE
TYPE ONE DIABETES JUST BEFORE
HIS SECOND BIRTHDAY. IT MEANS
THAT HE IS AN ECHO INDEPENDENT
FOR LIFE. YOU EITHER GET FOUR TO
TEN IN ONE SHOT PER DAY OR
CONTINUE WITH INC ONE DELIVERY
WITH A PALM. IT'S LIKE WALKING
ON EGGSHELLS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
WE CONSTANTLY MONITOR HIS BLOOD
SUGAR. IF IT'S TOO HIGH HE GETS
HIS PHONE WHEN HE COULD GO INTO
DIABETIC KETOACIDOSIS AND DIE.
IF HE'S TOO LOW SHE'LL HAVE A
SEIZURE YOU COULD HAVE BRAIN
DAMAGE OR DIE. ALMOST EVERY
NIGHT I WAKE UP TO ALARMS ONE
WHO CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITOR.
IT COULD BE BECAUSE THE SUGARS
ARE OUT OF RANGE WE HAVE A
SINGLE LOCKED OR ANY OTHER
NUMBER OF REASONS. WITH MY HEART
POUNDING I RUN AND I STUMBLE IN
MY KIDS ROOM. THE FATE OF MY
PLAN OKAY. IN A DARKLY POKING A
FINGER TO GIVE BLOOD SUGAR
READING AND WE DO IT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. WE OFTEN FALL ASLEEP NEXT
TO HIM JUST TO MAKE SURE HE
PICKED. CURRENTLY SEBASTIAN
NEEDS ABOUT ONE AND A HALF FILED
A SHORT TERM ACTING INSULIN A
MONTH TO KEEP THEM ALIVE. WE
JUST STARTED A NEW PUMP THAT
USES EVEN MORE IMPORTANT I'M NOT
THE VERY MOMENT I'M WORKING
WITH- PHARMACISTS TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO CONVINCE HER
INSURANCE COMPANY. TO COVER THE
NEW HIGHER AMOUNT THAN WHAT WE
NEED. THE RELIEF ON THE COST OF
EMPLOYMENT SENATE BILL FOUR
SEVEN THREE WE'LL GET TO
FAMILIES LIVING WITH INSULIN
DEPENDENT DIABETES. MEANS THE
WORLD TO US. IT IS LITERALLY
LIFE SAVING. WE ASK FOR YOUR
HELP. LET ME URGE YOU TO PASS AT
THE FOURTH SEVEN THREE. AN
ADDITIONALLY I WANT TO ADD A BIG
PERSONAL THANK YOU TO SENATOR
PAT BATES. YOU'RE A CLOSE FRIEND
OF OUR FAMILY AND WE'RE SO
GRATEFUL THAT YOU TAKEN UP THIS
WORTHY CAUSE. I MEAN HALF OF MY
FRIENDS A BASTION OF MY FAMILY.
THANK YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH
HELLO LET'S MOVE ON TO A SHARE
CONSOLIDATION AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION. YOU HAVE. A MINUTE
AND FIFTEEN SECONDS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR GOOD EVENING AND GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE GONZALEZ MAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
DIABETES ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE FOUR SEVEN THREE
WE WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN OUR
REMARKS BY THINKING THE AUTHOR
FOR BEING A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
THE DIABETES COMMUNITY. AS WELL
AS MISTER CHAIR FOR BEING A
STRONG ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIANS
LIVING WITH CHRONIC DISEASE
ACCORDING TO THE CDC MORE THAN
THREE MILLION OR 10% OF
CALIFORNIA'S ADULT POPULATION
HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
DIABETES. THE PREVALENCE
INCREASES WITH AGE ONE OUT OF
EVERY SIX ADULT CALIFORNIANS AGE
SIXTY FIVE IN ABOUT HALF THANK
YOU JP AND IT'S RATED HIGHER
AMONG MINORITIES CALIFORNIANS
WITH LOW INCOME AND EIGHTY EIGHT
PATIENT SURVEY CONFIRMS THAT
MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO FACE HIGH
OUT OF POCKET COSTS AGAIN. OR
NOT AND HEARING TO THEIR
DIABETES CARE PLAN AND INSTEAD
ARE RATIONING AND ONE FOR
FINANCIAL REASONS. INSULIN IS IT
CENTRAL TO MAINTAINING
APPROPRIATE BLUE BLOOD GLUCOSE
LEVELS AND REDUCING THE RISK OF
COMPLICATIONS FROM COKE AT
NINETEEN I THINK FOR SEVEN THREE
PART OF THE MOVEMENT THAT IS
SWEEPING THE NATION AT BOTH THE
STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL IN AN
EFFORT TO PROTECT PEOPLE LIVING
WITH DIABETES. AND WANT TO
PROVIDE PARTICULARLY IN THE ERA
OF CODE AT NINETEEN NOW IN
MEDICAL DEBT NINETEEN YEP THEY
CAN MAKE AND IT'S HIGH IMPACT ON
THE HYBRID COPULATION THE
PRODUCT. I THANK THE D. EIGHT
MARKET CALL TO ELIMINATE COSTLY. TO LIFE SAVING. THANKS FOR. WE
THEREFORE ASK YOUR EYES OUT.
THANK YOU NOW LET'S MOVE TO
OTHER ADDITIONAL AND NAME OR
DOES ONLY WILL BEGIN WITH THE
PUBLIC. UP PLEASE BEGIN I THANK
YOU MR CHARMERS MY NAME IS FRED
NO WE'RE REPRESENTING PHARMA IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
PUBLIC GALLERY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TO WITNESSES WHO
SHOULD TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
FOUR SEVEN THREE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOT AT T.
OPERATORS GOING TO BRIEFLY GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND THE PLACE
YOU DIRECTLY BACK INTO THE
QUEUE. SO AGAIN. I SHOW SUPPORT
SUPPORT FOR SP FOUR SEVEN THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. PUBLIC
PLEASE. OKAY WHAT PART HAS BEEN
QUEUING UP FOR ANYBODY ELSE
GOING AT ONE ZERO TWO EXPRESSED
SUPPORT THE SP FOUR SEVEN THREE
. AND WE'LL GO. WHY NOT ONE
THIRTY SIX YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON FIELDING GRIEVES OF
VIACOM CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
EXLINE. THANK YOU AND THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SHOW SUPPORT. AND MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE IS GIVING UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR SEVENTY
THREE WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES AND
REGISTERED OPPOSITION FOR
TESTIMONY- SO MODERATE PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE JED HAMPTON
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS. STEPHANIE
WATKINS FROM DISSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES BEGIN WITH
THE JET HAMPTON- YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
TOGETHER FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. YEAH HEY MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GET HANDS ON WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS REGRETTABLY HERE IN
OPPOSITION THAT BEFORE SEVENTY
THREE. FIRST WE WANT TO STATE
THAT WE ARE THE YEAH WE
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND AND
SYMPATHIZE WITH PATIENTS WERE
BURDENED WITH HIGH CONFIDENCE
ONE. AND WE SHARE ARE YOU
WILLING TO REPLACE RATIONS THAT
THE EXPONENTIAL RISE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES
CONTINUE TO DRIVE INCREASING
COSTS WITHIN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. WE CONTINUALLY AND
SEPARATELY EXPRESSED THAT
ADDRESSING THE PORTABILITY
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. IS CRITICAL
TO MAINTAINING. AFFORDABILITY
PARMALEE. BASICALLY FOR AN- IF
YOU PER HAVE COST INCREASE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH NO END IN
SIGHT. HE IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THESE PRICES CONTINUE
TO INCREASE WITHOUT ANY MAJOR
MEDICAL IMPROVEMENT THE DROUGHT
. PROGRESSIVELY AT BEFORE
SEVENTY THREE DOES NOT NEED A
TEMPERATURE AT THAT PRICE
INCREASES IMPLEMENTED BY THE
MANUFACTURERS AND I THOUGHT.
WELL YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY LIMIT PATIENT COST
SHARING FOR ALL PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS. FOR THIRTY DAY SUPPLY.
THE CAP WAS CAREFULLY AND
BUCKLING DOES SHE EXPECT
PROTECT. ALL CONSUMERS FROM
HYPOTHETICALLY DRUGS WHILE
ENSURING THAT. THE OVERALL COST
OF HEALTHCARE IN PORTABLE. AND
AT FORTY THREE IN ITS CURRENT
FORM DIRECTLY INTERFERES WITH
APPLE I. STATUS IN ARBITRARY
PRICE HAPPENING PLAN WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
TYPE RIGHT. WHICH IS THE EVER
INCREASING PRICE THE DRUG
MANUFACTURER TARGET THE FLIGHT
THEY NEED DR. WE DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AMENDMENT THAT
ARE COMING OUT OF ME TODAY AND
WILL BE WORKING WITH OUR
MEMBERS. THE ONLY THING WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE FOUR SEVENTY
THREE I WILL INCREASE THE COST
OF PREMIUMS FOR ALL OF OUR
ENROLLEES. AFFECTED UNDERSCORED
IN CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS OF
YOUR PROGRAM THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THAT WHICH PROJECTED THAT BILL
INCREASE. BY APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. ONE MEMBER
MEMBER COMPANIES REMAIN
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING THE BEST
POSSIBLE CARE PERSONALLY. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS MEASURE WILL
NEED TO BE DRIVE UP HEALTHCARE
COSTS AT THE WORST POSSIBLE TIME
AT THE COMPLETE OKAY AWAY OF THE
NINETEEN ENDEMIC. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THAT BEFORE SEVENTY THREE. I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING. WITH
WITH THE OFFER ON THIS MEASURE.
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE NUMBER ON SO WHAT- YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE TO SEVEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STEPHANIE WATKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS WITH
RESPECT AT THE FOUR SEVENTY
THREE. PERFECT ACTOR MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTED ALSO
HIGHLIGHT YOUR CONCERNS
REGARDING THE IMPACT THIS
MEASURE COULD HAVE ON THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. I WOULD PREDICT THE
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S PATIENT COST SHARING FOR
ALL PRESCRIPTION DIRECTED TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS FOR A
THIRTY DAY SUPPLY. THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH I AM NOT GOING TO GO SHE
DID IN ORDER TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM THE HIGH COST OF
SPECIALTY DRUGS WHILE INSURING
THAT THE COST OF HEALTHCARE
RIPPING INTO CORTICAL. BILL
DIRECTLY INTERFERES A TACKLE AND
INCREASING THE COST OF PREMIUMS
FOR ALL INSURANCE ENROLLEES BY
TREATING INSULIN DRUGS
DIFFERENTLY. WHAT DO YOU THINK
THAT COST SHARING OF INSULIN
DRUG USE SOCIAL LIFE THAT
ADDITIONAL EXPENSE AGAINST ALL
RATEPAYERS. ULTIMATELY CREATING
WINNERS AND LOSERS WITHIN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM BY TREATING
INDIVIDUAL WRONG IS CURRENTLY
BASED ON SPECIFIC DISEASE. AND
OR DRUGS THAT THEY TAKE OUR
CONCERN WITH RESPECT TO THE
PORTABILITY- I DIGITAL IS
FURTHER. DEVELOP DEMENTIA
BERGMAN ALASTAIR AS IT WAS A MAN
IT. WOULD COST ME FIFTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITION ALL. CHANGING THE PRESSURE DRUG
BENEFITS IN THIS MAN MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR INSURE TO MEET
THEIR STOCK EVER. ACT VALUE.
WITHIN A ESPECIALLY MY BROWN
LEVEL. IF MANDATED REDUCTION IN
COST SHARING IMPACT ACTUAL VALUE
FOR PLANTING INSURERS MAYBE
FOURTH INCREASE OTHER COST
SHARING COMPONENTS IN ORDER TO
KEEP THE OVERALL BENEFIT DESIGN
WITHIN THE REQUIRED ACTION WROTE
ABOUT YOU. ADDRESSING
AFFORDABILITY OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS IN THE ABILITY OF THOSE
WHO NEED THEM TO ABSORB THE
RISING COST OF THE CRITICAL
CONTINUING ISSUE. ULTIMATELY IT
IS THE UNDERLYING RISING COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS THAT DRIVES
THE NEED FOR COST SHARING AND
FACTORED GREATLY INTO INCREASING
THE COST OF HEALTHCARE.
CURRENTLY PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ARE
THE SECOND HIGH EXPENSE INCLUDES
OUR HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL-
IMPRINT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE DOCTOR BUT
REGRETTABLY OUR PLEDGE TO TRY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELL
THEY'LL MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOUR SEVENTY THREE WILL BE OUT
OF THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON
THE PUBLIC GALLERY. MOVE ONTO A
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TWO
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR SEVENTY
THREE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU I
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO SP
FOUR SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE I GIVE YOU YOUR LIFE
NUMBER THE PLACEYOU BACK INTO
THE QUEUE WE'LL START WITH ONE
ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS THAT
NEED MORE WHILE ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
AND I REGRET PROPOSITION. THANK
YOU X. LINE. REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TWO OCT STRESS
OPPOSITION FOR SP FOUR SEVEN
THREE AND LINE ONE THIRTY THREE
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASHLEY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE A
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE THANK. WE
HAVE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR I THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. CENTER LABOR
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANNA THANK SENATOR BATES FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IT'S
JUST UNCONSCIONABLE THAT IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD INSULIN-
TO WOMEN WHO TESTIFIED IS LIKE
HUNDREDS OF OTHERS WHO THEIR
CHILDREN ARE BORN NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. WITH THIS DISEASE OR
IMMUNO COMPROMISED SYSTEM AND
THEN TO NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD
THE LIFESAVING DRUGS THAT THE
CHILD NEEDS I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE
THAT AS A PARENT. SO REALLY
REALLY EXCITED AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING
NINE SIR BATES- I TOO WANT TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
. YOU KNOW THAT WE WILL DISCUSS
THIS ISSUE BEFORE HEARING THIS
COMMITTEE MY PREFERENCE WOULD
HAVE BEEN IS THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A SOLUTION FOR CROSS THE
BOARD FOR ALL CHRONIC DISEASES
CERTAINLY- PATIENTS WHO NEED
INSULIN WHO HAVE DIABETES HAVE
TREMENDOUS NEEDS. I ALSO WANNA
RECOGNIZE THAT THEIR OTHER
CHRONIC DISEASES AS WELL WHERE-
THEY ALSO DESERVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT YOU HELD YOUR BILL
BACK TO GIVE ME A CHANCE TO SEE
WHETHER WE COULD ACTUALLY
NEGOTIATE SOMETHING THAT WAS
BROADER UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE
NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL YET- I HEARD
THE HEALTH PLANS SPECIFYING THE
DATA WANTED DISEASE BY DISEASE
APPROACH AND SO WE TRIED A NOT.
A BROADER APPROACH IT WASN'T
DISEASE BY DISEASE HOWEVER GIVEN
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO ADVANCE THAT POLICY FOR
WHICH WE DID OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL BECAUSE WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO WAIT BECAUSE
WE CAN'T SUCCEED IN IT AND ABOUT
THAT BROADER BILL. PATIENTS LIKE
THE CHILD OF KERRY **** AND
OTHER PATIENTS WITH DIABETES
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WAIT BECAUSE
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO MOVE THE
BROADER POLICY SO WELL CERTAINLY
I PREFER. THAT WE DO A BROADER
POLICY. I CERTAINLY I SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE AMENDMENT SO WE CAN
TAKE CARE OF SOME OF THE OTHER
ASPECTS OF DIABETES CARE. AND
AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH ME AND- BEING
PATIENT ALLOW ME TO THAT STANCE
TO TRY TO WORK OUT THE LARGER
ISSUES- BUT CERTAINLY BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO ADVANCE
THAT. WON SUPPORT YOU IN YOUR
EFFORTS SO THAT WE CAN AT LEAST
ADDRESS. THE PATIENTS WITH
DIABETES. AND WITH THAT IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER. CENTER GROVE
DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT. AM I
JUST HAVE TO MOVE YOUR BILL.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
GROVE- THE MOTIONS DO PASS
AMENDED THE FIRST MAN REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATE. SO
WITH THAT- CENTER BASE WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR I THINK THE FULL
VERY THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS ARE
BOTH ON. THE PART OF US
CERTAINLY THE PROPONENTS AND THE
OPPONENTS KNOWING THAT THIS IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN A VERY
COSTLY ONE. WHAT MISS ****
DIDN'T SHARE WITH YOU AS HER CAR
SPAGNOLI. APPROACHED ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT'S
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH AFTER THE DEDUCTIBLE.
UNLESS HE PAID SO. HI THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT PHONE BILL BACK
BUILD BETTER BACK AND NOW
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S. PROPOSALS ARE
THE GOVERNORS LOOKING OUT. SO I
THINK WE SEE THERE'S A NEED
THERE NOT JUST FOR THIS
PARTICULAR. BUT I THINK IF THIS
IS A GOOD START. THAT PEOPLE'S
LIVES HANG IN THE BALANCE
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS EXTREMELY
. PANDEMIC THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING HERE ON UN UP.
PLANET EARTH SO I. APPRECIATE IT
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS AND KNOW
I'M- A MEMBER I THINK SENATOR
RUBIO OPTICS. IN IN ME A CORE.
OF TO ANY ALL. WHO LIKE TO UP
AND A- I IT'S A WORKING. AND I'M
- ALL TO WORK WITH- DOCKED BATON
A CERTAIN I OF THE APPOINTED WE
COME TO. THAT HAVE. WITH THAT HI
. ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES AGAIN.
BILL BEEN MOVED BY GROW AND- THE
PATH AMENDED THE FIRST. WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HAN HI. CAN I AM
A LINDA'S. LINDA'S EYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN EIGEN SOLACE I CAN SELL
US I. GROVE. GROVE I HER TADO ON
TITLE I LLEVA I LEAVE I LEAVE
ALONE. HI IMAN I ROSS. ROSS HI
RUBIO. RUBIO EYELINER. HI WE- I
WANT. OKAY THE BILLS OUT ELEVEN
ZERO. ALL RIGHT AND IT LOOKS SO
WHAT THAT THAT CONCLUDES THIS
AGENDA FOR THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH. I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE. YOU COMEDIAN
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY INDIVIDUAL HEARING
RECORDS WHAT THANK YOUR
PARTICIPATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
I THANK EVERYONE HERE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WHAT
THANK ALL THE STAFF WHO WORKED
ON IT AND OF COURSE THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE MEMBERS ARE COMING
IN FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT
HEARING. WITH THAT- THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH IS NOW
ADJOURNED.